what do i do
i'll go c4 i guess
all right c6 sorry knight f6
will have an english okay let me go e3
there should be four i had this against
the running and
simply wrap it in blood
and he's thinking a bit at least
yeah this is a solid line
but i think like the extra
tempo means that
this must at least be playable right
okay bishop d3 looks normal
and then i think we go before
wait a sec maybe i cannot before
okay we'll play simpler instead
check bishop b4 and then after queen b6
will go b4
and my claim is that with the
that i will have some play with my
bishop bear although knight a6
i find fine somewhat annoying
and ruining my mood
a bit
[Music]
then not
okay i was thought i was sort of
threatening to go f4
apparently he's not not at all worried
about it
bishop b2 he can go knight e6
although then i have queen c3 and if f6
there's bishop b1 maybe
yeah i kind of like that there should be
seven now i can take a queen e4
and there's a double attack i also
have serious ideas of going eve of going
d4
that i just spotted
okay not not right away
i didn't like f5 for him at all bishop
b7 there still takes and
d4 i think
and obviously kind of take twice because
of bishop a3
with with a skewer um so you probably
also do something along the lines of
84 ed 4 and then 96 but
i believe
with the bishop against knight i should
be somewhat better here
and also with with a somewhat
somewhat more secure king
so we'll attack his queen with tempo
never a bad idea and occupy as many of
the lines as possible
rookie 8 was not possible because of
takes and then f5 is hanging
i guess this idea maybe to go f4
next am i worried about that
there is rook d5 f4 then i can take and
there's bishop a3
i kind of like that
take it and then i'll go with a3 or i
can also go a5
as a matter of fact i'll rubbish a3
seems simpler
yeah rook f5 this is what i was slightly
worried about
yeah that was a bit of a mess okay i
don't have much then
i still have a little bit
c4 i think
i am somewhat better here
one on f4 is a little bit weak
and the pin
might be a little bit annoying so i
think i'll take on c5 now
and he made just a blender f4
yeah okay he gets this
that's roxy4
that was maybe a tad on the naive side
but still i'll try and try and do
something here
you kind of you cannot force the draw
immediately at the very least
okay three i think
oh now he tries i know this doesn't
force a draw this doesn't force the draw
at all
he does get to exchange a pawn but now
his rook
is fairly passive i don't think this was
necessarily a good idea
okay we'll give in some space
he will have some pretty difficult
questions to answer
i'm not worried about this king going to
the queen side at all
because my counterplay if you can call
it that will be
very very strong on the king side
no this doesn't work fine
i think you're gonna just take and push
f4 probably now
seems pretty clean
all right no what am i doing tanking
back with the king i'll just take back
to the rook
and if king b5 rook b5 jack
taken g5 should be comfortably ahead in
that race
now yeah i'll take that i'll push
okay yeah i can just push
r28 that check on f5 and kg5 oh he has
no kind of play
yeah this is absolutely dead lost i
think he made a very instructive mistake
there when he went for
when he went for the plan with a6
exchanging and then
it meant it meant that i did
get to exchange a pawn but also his work
became really really passive
so i don't think overall it was a
it was a worthwhile trade for him
oh